oh lost oh no
But we are looking for a lost toy
She's a figurine used to be on that lamp in the window name's Bo Peep Bo Peep. Oh, yes. I know Bo
You do hop on in we'll take you to her
Grab well
Okay, this is the scene where woody meets Bo Yeah
right nine years later in the playground and so we'll start here where
Bo over here is that we stole hell. Yeah. Yeah
subtitle by redhoodyperson
And if you remember the bow is lost girl outside. So she has no idea what he's past
And this is what he's she's learning about that no, no, no
No, he he went off to college but he gave us to Bonnie. She's this you have a little girl no way
Yeah, yeah, it's why I'm out here
Her other toy is trapped in this antique store and I have two second-chance antiques. We know that store
That's great. That is great. If you know the store you could really help me find him
Let's try one more way where you're really flailing here for she's gonna walk away. Oh
Okay, these are this is every attempt to try and pull her back to okay, she's done
She's not gonna go do it and I have to I have to pull out the heavy artillery. Okay. All right
No, no. No, but hey, but you see
body needs him just like
Molly needed you you like that upper register. I still have since 95
Still have a squeaky thirteen-year-olds voice. They say it's gonna change one of these years. Well, that's woody, right?
There's a great woody line here which is but he gave us the body
Bonnie needs him to get through kindergarten
Look who jumped 40 school buses and landed back into my life. Hi Duke
Who's the cowboy Duke meet? Woody? What do you mean Duke? Kaboom?
Canada's greatest stunt man, huh? Oh, yeah, huh, huh?
Yes, huh - hold on one more. Oh
Yeah, great sooo, one more and the same kind of idea where Duke is just reciting the commercial
It's constantly playing in his head there, right?
But do you want do you want Duke doing the commercial or do you want what the Duke?
Like should I be doing the voiceover of the commercial like Duke? Kaboom Canada's greatest stuntman, but if it was the commercial
Maybe it would be different like Duke kaboom. Canada's greatest stuntman
Look who jumped 40 school buses and landed back into my life. Hi Duke
Who's the cowboy Duke woody? Uh
Duke meet woody woody mean Duke kaboom Canada's greatest stuntman, huh? Oh, yeah ha ha
Ha ha he's posing Duke Duke. We need to hold on one more. Oh, yeah
What brings you back Pete we need your help Gabby Gabby has his toy and my sheep no Billy Goats Gruff
Those are my girls. She thinks he is. Yeah, he's been she lost a while exactly
She learns that he has a kid still look no later on
seven
Fantastic years 7 you would not believe the things that I have seen when you're talking about the rag doll
He told you about it's like you you're telling her the secret you guys had talked about him right gossips about him over the years
Is that a whisper? Yeah, looks like she's alright on her shoulder. So you're just being you don't want woody to hear it
Whoa, who's this?
You remember the rag doll? I told you about the cowboy
Yep. No way don't stare. I'm totally staring
Woody this is giggle, Mick dimples
Hey
Nice find girls. Where do you get all this stuff here and there, you know some kids play rougher than others
So I try to be prepared. How long have you been out on your own?
Seven fantastic years seven, you would not believe the things I have seen
All right
this is giggles intro into the film and
Woody has just met with Bo and now if I was gonna introduce cables to would Ethan gigs
Yo, come on out. There's someone I'd like you to meet be right down
So what's the situation we had an out of town or whoa, who's this you the ragdoll? I told you about the cowboy. Yep
No way
Don't stare I'm totally staring. Okay. Let's try one more where
When we're here with giggle here. She says what's the situation she's in full police officer mode
And then when she sees woody she snaps right out of it for what? Who's this? Okay, that's the same thing where
She realizes he's a cop. She goes right into his shop and top talking shop with him. Got it. Okay, okay
Perfect gigs yo, come on out there someone I'd like you to meet be right down
What's the situation so we heading out of town or whoa, who's this? You remember the rag doll? I told you about the cowboy
Yep, no wait
Don't stare I'm totally staring. Whoa you tell me he was a cop
Howdy Sheriff
Officer giggle mcdhh impuls here and pet patrol from minneapolis. Yeah search and rescue and
caterpillars miniature poodles spiders, okay
This is the scene. This is the intro of ducky money. Yep. Yep
And so just remember that buzz is tied in to the game and you guys are so angry that he's there. That's right
So I'll read opposite you with bunny and Buzz. Okay. Hey Lightyear. Hey up here astro boy
If you think you could just show up and take our top prize spot you're wrong. You did roll. You don't understand. I'm trying to
Cheat the system and get with a kid. Yeah, we know no, I need a childish shower you with unconditional love join the club pal
Come on, help me get out of here. I'll help you with
Bunny what are you doing? Hmm, I can't reach a man help me out here. Come on. Oh, sorry ducky yet
I'm not a mind-reader, you know, what's not to understand, huh?
You gonna make me say it what
With these tiny legs
I cannot reach without your help record on the first page
If you just be more angry at this guy, like really he's he's ruined your chances of ever getting with a kid
Right right gosh, dang, you can do with them. Angry Zig me. Okay?
This is the one in the RV we're just talking about where it's between Buzz and Woody what he's sitting there
This is the yeah, I think it first learns about the inner voice. Is this it? Yeah, this is it
I'm gonna take the next watch Oh keep an eye on porky. No, no
No, I need to do this a little voice inside me. We never leave me alone if I gave up
What do you think it is who the voice inside? Eeeh who do you think it is fascinating?
So your inner voice
Advises you what?
All right. So this is where Woody has is missing and Buzz gonna go into action here in the RV, so
Then on the bed the whispering to each other and Buzz realizes that
What he was right thing the entire time there's a secret mission in uncharted space
No time to explain attack. All right, this is scene
we're gonna do next is the the interesting of Gabby Gabby and so woody in for Kia come into the store and
We're gonna start here where Gabby Woody's talking about Bo Peep. And the first time I see them in person Dexter. Oh,
The story's about to open don't worry, we'll take you where no one will see us. Oh, no. No, we can't stay
Yes, you can
Bo Peep oh
Yes, I know Bo you do hop on in we'll take you to her
Oh, you don't have to do that Benz mix it up. Oh, well, okay Benson be careful with our new friends
Well, I want service. Uh, thank you for your help. I haven't seen Bo in years
May I ask when were you made you you really you're just trying to get to
Figure out exactly what you need and so when we get to page
Two well as soon as he's
Saying oh, thanks for your help you go right into
Excuse me, when were you made? So like your your goal has completely changed to your own personal goals. Thank you
got him in your trap and now you
Start picking away out
Gee, I wonder if we were made in the same Factory. Wouldn't that be something I gotta say?
You are in great condition. Um, great. Let's try one more where you're being very
Defiant here. Yes
Temper tantrum what? Yes it not that. Oh and then we know you get to here. Like here's the one thing you do know like
this this and this
Okay, no, no, I am NOT a toy I'm a sport be quiet
I was made for soup salad, maybe chili and then the trash I am
Let me give you a different direction, but it's pretty much the same direction
Really try and forcibly to understand that you are not a toy whoever I give you like you he's been running this for
For-4 seems in your knees. Listen, you're not getting it right. I'm trash
Porky porky I am NOT a toy. I'm a spork be quiet
I was made for soup salad, maybe chili and then the trash I'm winner
I'm
trash trash trash
Trash trash trash trash
You